a few days ago i shared 10 of my
favorite css techniques
and you guys responded with nearly a
thousand comments of your own pro tips
tips that are so good that they deserve
their own video
the first one from skylark murphy is
really simple yet really powerful
basically it boils down to use relative
units when possible over static pixel
values for example
when designing a responsive layout you
might have headings or containers with
fixed pixel values for margin and
padding then you might have a media
query to change those values on smaller
screens
not only is this difficult to maintain
but it doesn't work very well on devices
that scale fonts automatically
instead of fixed units like pixels we
can use relative units like
m or rem m will calculate the size
automatically
based on the font size of its nearest
parent if the parent has a font size of
16 pixels
then 2m would compute to 32 pixels as an
alternative
you could use rem which is relative to
the root font size i generally find that
one more useful when working with margin
and padding
but most importantly notice how that got
rid of the media query and one thing
i'll add is that there are more relative
units than just
m and rem one of which is ch or
character width
now if you're really serious about
design you may have read the elements of
typographic style by robert bringhurst
which says that the optimal size for a
paragraph is between
45 and 75 characters a cool trick is
that we can enforce that rule using the
clamp function i showed you in the
previous video
use it to make the min width 45
characters the preferred width 50
and the max width 75 characters and now
every paragraph will be the absolute
perfect width now our next tip is also
very simple but also one that will
change your life
dimitra says to use hsl colors over hex
or rgb
rgb stands for red green blue where each
mix of the color can be a value from 0
to
255. hexadecimal contains the same
information but in a more compact format
that's even harder to interpret
hsl on the other hand stands for hue
saturation and lightness
and that format makes it way easier to
compute a nice looking color palette if
you have a hex color in vs code
go ahead and hover over it then click on
the top to bring up hsl mode on the
right you'll notice we have our cue
control which controls the color itself
then on the main box if you move from
left to right
it will control the saturation or
intensity of the color and if you move
up and down
it will control the lightness or
brightness of it and optionally you can
add a fourth value for opacity what's
really cool though is if you want to
make a color palette quickly you can
simply choose a saturation and lightness
then increment the hue by a certain
amount like 25
in this case and now we have a bunch of
colors that look like they belong
together
and that brings us to our third tip from
nsharma an issue i often see on websites
that have a fixed nav bar
is that when you go to an anchor link
the page will automatically scroll but
then the heading is covered by the fixed
nav bar
it turns out there's an obscure property
called scroll padding top or just scroll
padding for all the other sides which
will add additional padding when the
browser automatically scrolls to that
anchor and that gives us an easy way to
fix a very common yet very annoying bug
if you saw your comment in this video
hit me up via email or slack because you
just want yourself a free t-shirt thanks
for watching
and i will see you in the next one